pregnancy is the time period during
which a baby develops inside your uterus
it usually lasts about 40 weeks starting
from the first day of your last
menstrual period
these 40 weeks are grouped into three
segments called trimesters
the second trimester goes from week 14
through the end of week 27.
at the beginning of the second trimester
your baby now called a fetus is around
three inches long from head to rump
around this time your baby's eyelids
close
and the sex organs begin to form on the
outside of the body
by week 16 your baby grows to be about
five inches long
fine hair called lenugo begins to
develop on the head
and the mouth begins to make sucking
motions
at 20 weeks your baby can hear and
swallow
[Music]
and the baby is more active
you may feel this as a fluttering in
your lower belly
in the middle of this trimester you may
have an ultrasound exam it will check
your baby's movement heart rate and size
sometimes the baby's sex may be visible
at 24 weeks the lungs are formed but
aren't ready to work outside of the
uterus
[Music]
the heartbeat can be heard with a
stethoscope
[Music]
by the end of the second trimester your
baby has gained more weight and is about
a foot long from head to rump
you may find that you feel better during
this trimester than you did during the
first three months
some of the changes you may notice
include less nausea and fatigue
darker skin around your nipples
a dark line on your skin from your belly
button to your groin called the Linea
[__]
stretch marks on your belly breasts
thighs or buttocks
swelling in your face fingers and ankles
and feeling your baby move
if you have any questions about how your
baby is developing or concerns about how
you're feeling talk to your health care
provider